[Music]
dur in the week we told you submit your
questions ahead of time did we do that
yes or no all right so we're not taking
questions from the congregation we're
only dealing with the ones that were
submitted and are on this sheet are you
following me all right you look unhappy
but that's the rule for today only the
questions on this sheet okay sister
Esther come
can sit let me pray first father james:
15 says if any of you lack wisdom let
him ask of God give me the wisdom I pray
in Jesus name amen question
one does living in sin stop God from
answering prayers especially big prayer
requests that require Deliverance does
living in sin prevent God from answering
prayers go to Proverbs
28 uh psalm 66 sorry Verse 18 Psalm
66:18 do living in sin prevent God from
answering prayers Psalm
66:18 do we have
that read with me if I regard iniquity
in my heart the Lord
will not hear
me now go to Isaiah chapter
1 in Isaiah chapter 1 God is criticizing
the Israelites for bringing all these
sacrifices without bringing their hearts
you see so the sacrifices were
meaningless here's what he says to them
in verse 15 of Isaiah 1 what does that
say
Isaiah 1:15 says what and when ye spread
forth your hands I will hide my face
from you yeah my eyes from your year
when you make many prayers I will not
hear why because of all the sins they
were
practicing Isaiah 59 read from verse
one Isaiah
59 reading from verse one we're
answering the question do active sins
interfere with God's answering of
prayers Isaiah 59 reading from verse one
behold the Lord's hand is not shortened
that it cannot save come on neither his
ear heavy that it cannot hear but your
iniquities have separated between you
and your God and His your sins have hid
his face from you finish verse that he
will not hear there's one thing that
blocks prayers from being answered is
active sin
you want your prayers
answered get your sins
confessed
forgiven you see God cannot be
manipulated God is not someone you just
toss around live any life you want and
then ask for everything you want from
God someone wrote me very disappointed a
relationship did not work out and he
wrote me he said I don't understand I
ask God to bless my
plans so I wrote back and said next time
ask God to reveal his plans for you
don't ask God to bless your plans
because you don't know what a good plan
is ask God to reveal his
plan so he's disappointed God didn't
bless my plans but he wasn't aware of
what he was saying you see oh no God
doesn't exist to bless our plans we
should go to God and ask him what is
your plan for me or if you have a plan
you say father do you approve not just
bless me my plan do you approve you stay
out of a lot of trouble that way next
question um Can a prayer be answered if
we do not ask in the name of Jesus
Christ John 14:13-14
in the times of ignorance God
overlooks when a person genuinely does
not know God
overlooks but to him that knoweth to do
good and doeth it not it is sin you see
Jesus tells us ask in his name there's a
reason for
that there is nothing God can do for you
or for me unless it is done through
Jesus
Christ now this wasn't the case before
sin but when Adam sinned everything that
God could do for mankind had to go
through Jesus Christ and so Jesus says
pray in my name his name represents who
he is his life his divinity his perfect
Humanity the fact that he's Creator he's
savior all of that you must understand
as the name of Jesus Christ the one who
paid the penalty for my sins the one who
sacrificed satisfied the father in the
name of Jesus it is not Abracadabra to
open any whatever it is not open sesame
that's not what the name of Jesus is the
name of of Jesus is your acknowledgment
of his divinity his Humanity his role as
Creator his role as Savior his sinless
life in the name of
Jesus when you know you should and you
don't you endanger the possibility of
having your prayers answered because God
is not the author of confusion God does
things in a very disciplined way really
he
does all right so please pray in the
name of Jesus not in the name of the
father I've heard people pray father do
this do that in your name I
pray in the name of Jesus and people do
that because they're not conscious of
the tremendous significance of praying
in the name of
Jesus but you must have a relationship
with him in Acts chapter 19 there were
some exorcists professional exorcists
they noticed that Paul cast out demons
in the name of Jesus so they tried and
they said in the name of Jesus that Paul
talks about because they didn't know
Christ personally the demons started to
beat these men all seven ran out of the
house naked and
bleeding just saying Jesus does not have
power because a lot of men in Hispanic
countries are called Jesus are you
following me it's j s us you have to
understand who is he what did he stand
for what does he do now that's the name
of Jesus when you know you should do it
all right because anything Jesus puts to
the father on your behalf the father
will answer anything Christ takes to the
father on your behalf the father will
answer next question how do I pray
effectively for my marriage family life
and over my children you pray through
the word of God read the question again
please how do I pray effectively for my
marriage family life and over my
children you pray biblically here's what
I mean
when um when
Jehoshaphat was threatened by a large
army go to 2 Chronicles chapter
20 2 Chronicles chapter
20 let's read from verse six now the
ammonites and two of
armies they came to attack the kingdom
of Judah Jehoshaphat called all all the
citizens to Jerusalem they gathered
around the temple and Jehoshaphat starts
to pray to God about this
threat read verse six what does that
say come on read out loud and said oh
lord of our father are not
thou
stop what is Jehoshaphat
doing is there any Bible verse that says
God is the god of Heaven come on
yes now he says oh Lord God of our
fathers art not thou God in heaven what
is he V virtually
quoting Bible
verse so he's confronting god with his
word aren't you God in heaven the Bible
says he is what do you think God said if
you can listen with the ear of Faith
what you hear God saying yes read the
next
statement not not Thou come on read let
me hear you
rulest not thou over all the kingdoms
does the bible say that yes what do you
hear God saying yes you read all the way
down to verse 11 or verse 10 Jehoshaphat
just reminds didn't you do this didn't
you say didn't you say that and God has
to keep saying yes yes
yes then he tells God do something for
us and did God do it yes
praying through the Bible for instance
let's say your child has left the
church you say dear God you've said in
Isaiah
49:25 I will save thy
children please go get my child you do
it your way it may cause pain you do
it you
broke you say father didn't you
say I will pour you out a blessing they
shall not be room enough to didn't you
say that what does God have to say
yes when you pray whether for your
marriage your children pray
biblically are you following me but you
have to know the Bible verse is
necessary are you f you have to study
the word of God to pray biblically you
must know the word of God so whether you
pray you pray over your marriage father
didn't you say in Malachi 26 the Lord
God of Israel hateth putting
away now my wife is acting up on my
husband is acting up there's a
possibility of divorce didn't you say
you hate putting away well father do
something pray Through the Bible because
when you present god with his word God
has no option but to act God will never
deny his word it's not a way of painting
God into a corner do you have that
expression okay it is simply saying this
is what you
said you said that stick by it please
you'll be surprised God will never deny
his word regardless of what you pray for
pray through the word of God bu you but
you must know the
word because praying is not an isolated
act just to get you what you want
praying is fellowship with God are you
with me whether you need anything or not
and we always need Grace next
question as the head of my household how
do I run it effectively and in the way
of
God you lead out spiritually as a head
of the
household you're the head of the house
you're not the
Tyrant you're not the boss you're the
head and biblical headship is service
are you following me so you have to lead
out in spiritual things you've got to
set the example so that you lead that
way let's go to Ephesians chapter 5
may I take a sip of this you know I hate
doing it but I've been talking all day
is that okay all
right Ephesians
5 let's read from verse 22 what does
that say Wives come on submit yourselves
to your own husbands as unto the Lord
for the husband come on is the head of
the wife e even as Christ is the head of
the church now carefully now and he is
the savior of the body the husband is
the savior of the body of the family as
verily as Christ is the savior of the
body the church
now finish the
verse let's read verse 25 husbands love
your wives even as Christ also loved the
church and gave himself for it
now any woman will follow a man who's
willing to die for her are you following
me not willing to kill her willing to
die for her as Christ was prepared and
actually died for the church now you ask
the husband how should he lead out he
leads out by example first spiritually
because the man is the priest make sure
the family prays in the morning prays at
night make sure the children are taught
the word make sure the children are
taken to church and not sent
you're not listening to me don't send
them to church take them to
church don't hire someone to teach them
the Bible you teach them
leadership begins spiritually
first much prayer with the family and by
yourself Christ would rise early at
night or early in the morning when
everyone was sleeping to pray a
spiritual father while the mother is
snoring and the children are snoring
he's in some corner of the house come on
praying because he's the house band are
you with me he's the house
band he's not a boss he's a head and
headship in the Bible is service so
Christ said even as the son of man came
not to be ministered unto but to
minister first spiritually the word of
God
family that lives by the word of God is
a family Bound for the
kingdom the father cannot put his career
above the spiritual welfare of the
family if he does that he should not
have had a
family all right next
question if one pays Lola or doy for a
wife and obtains a marriage certificate
via court is this Union still blessed by
God when I come from a culture with no
doola that's so but for what from what
I've learned and picked up but I don't
speak with
authority there are two levels of
recognition in many African cultures the
traditional and the formal or
governmental uh I was counseling a
couple online several uh about a year
ago and they told me we paid Lola and
according to tradition we recognize this
matter I said well I don't know if you
recognize you recognize make sure the
government recognizes that then I then
they said later on we'll have a church
service so you have to find out what the
culture tradition is because I don't
know is maybe different in Zimbabwe from
Angolo mosek South Africa BW maybe I
don't know but you find out what is uh
the tradition and you make sure you
behave appropriately we don't want you
living together when you're not really
husband and wife so just familiarize
yourself with the customs of both the
culture and what the government
requires because you must be married in
the site not only of your tribe but also
of the government under which you you
are living and also as a Christian in
the sight of
God let me say something no I won't say
it go ahead next question no no no no no
no no no no no when the spirit says
don't say it don't say it all right next
question do dreams in our time still
have meaning and if so what does it mean
to always be running from danger do
dreams still have meaning in our time
God can give a dream to anyone he wants
let me say this quickly don't depend on
dreams when God gave dreams to Pharaoh
back in Genesis 39 uh 41 and he gave
dreams to Nebuchadnezzar there was no
Bible are you following me there was no
Bible but as the Bible was developed
first the Old Testament then the new
you'll observe that dreams became fewer
and fewer and fewer God's primary means
of communication is thus Seth the Lord
not dreams now I did not say God never
gives dreams I simply said God's primary
method of communication is his word if
we all depended on dreams we would put
the Bible on the
shelf and God will not develop a
situation that causes you and me to
skirt around his word this is how he
communicates primarily but God can
choose to give an individual a Dream
from time to time I don't know what it
means to be what
running from danger maybe if you confess
your sins you'll have different dreams
but I don't know what it means to be
constantly running from danger and I
don't I'm not Daniel but don't depend on
dreams talk to God through his word next
question is there anything such as
rebaptism I was baptized in 2015 and
since then have lived a sinful life I am
ashamed of it and would like to start a
fresh please advise but we read in Acts
chapter 9 19: 5 when they heard this
they were baptized in the name of the
Lord Jesus there were 12 disciples whom
Paul re-baptized because there was vital
Bible information they did not have he
taught them and he re-baptized them now
Ela white writes in uh evangelism page
375 paragraph 2 when a soul is truly
reconverted let that Soul be re-baptized
so rebaptism is in the Bible and the
writings of our Prophet Ellen White but
don't get re-baptized each time you
sneeze or anything of the kind that's
not what she's saying if there's a Recon
you know some people come to church
Faithfully but they have no connection
with Christ let me tell you the story I
was in a South Korea preaching for a
weekend made a call for baptism and
rebaptism 50s something people
came to
rebaptism and I took them to a room to
speak to them and a retired Minister
joined me he was from South Africa and
he gave a personal experience he said in
the middle of his ministry he went to
the conference president and requested
to be re-baptized well naturally the
president was taken aback and he began
to what did this man do he said I've
done nothing but my life has not grown
in 20
years I run the church meet my goals the
tithe is up but I have not grown I want
to start again with my God the president
said well let's baptize you at night so
nobody sees he said no no no no no no no
baptize me in the day right in front of
my church because there are people in my
church who need to make the same
decision who have never grown in all
this
time I was at another church somewhere
preaching a week of prayer the associate
pastor God re-baptized because he was
reconverted I was in another place
during a week of prayer the pastor's
wife and son got re-baptized and he
re-baptized both of them rebaptism is
perfectly uh biblical and perfectly
legitimate all right but don't make it a
weekly habit that's what I'm trying to
tell
you please explain John 3: 1-7 the text
implies we are all born Sinners and no
man can see the kingdom of God unless
they are born of water and the Holy
Spirit the SDA church does not baptize
young children therefore will they enter
Heaven should they die at that age many
a time in the Bible God punished and
destroyed cities babies included because
of the decisions of the parents mhm all
right John 31-7 there was a man of the
Pharisees named Nicodemus a ruler of the
Jews the same came to Jesus by night and
said unto him Rabbi we know that thou
are a teacher sent from God for no man
can do these Miracles which thou doest
except God be with him Jesus answered
and said unto him verily verily I say
unto you except a man be born again he
cannot see the kingdom of God Nicodemus
saith unto him how can a man be born
when he's old can he enter the second
time into his mother's womb and be born
Jesus answered verily verily I say unto
you except a man be born of water and of
the spirit he cannot enter the kingdom
of God can't see it can't enter it that
which is born of the flesh is flesh that
which is born of the spirit is Spirit
now the question says we're born sinners
now I need to respond to that carefully
it is more accurate to say we're all
born in need of a
savior no one is born guilty of Adam's
sin that's called original sin the
church does not believe that no one is
born guilty of Adam's sin we're all born
with a condition that needs a savior to
Deliver Us from it every single human
being needs a savior if a baby is born
and a baby is born in a coma and is
attached to a machine and a baby lives
15 years on that machine that baby still
needs a
savior even though he or she has never
made a moral choice to offend God once
you were born into this world since Adam
sinned you need a savior but no one is
born guilty of Adam's sin we do not
believe in original sin now when babies
die yes God has requested on occasions
everyone be killed in a particular city
or town he has done that but God knows
the end from the beginning God knows
what that child would become had the
child lived But ultimately even if we
can't explain it we know from Psalm
145:1 17 the Lord is righteous in all
his ways and holy in all his works
whatever God does is right even though
we do not understand our understanding
is limited and I mean severely limited
when it comes to understanding the
actions of God anything God does is
right so we don't know what will happen
to the babies we do know that God is a
merciful god I will have mercy unto whom
I will have mercy we do know that God is
very unwilling that anyone should p
we do know that God doesn't punish the
innocent because of the misbehavior of
the guilty that's as far as I can
go some say the seventh day Adventists
are a branch of the Catholicism how do
we know it is the true church some say
what the Seventh Day Adventist is a
branch a branch of the Catholic church
church is what's the opposite to Black
what's the opposite to tall what's the
opposite to Fat come on what's the
opposite to Sweet
what the opposite to
Adventist
yeah you better believe it we are not a
branch of the Catholic church we were
raised up to expose the man of sin are
you with me we were raised up as an
antidote when I say antidote as an agent
under the control of Christ to work
against what the Beast does or the man
of sin or the two or the uh the little
horn in Daniel 7 or the leopard-like
beast in Revelation 13 that's our
function to
oppose all the errors that flow from the
Roman Church we are not an extension now
some of us behave that
way there's a lot of Adventists who were
Adventist Catholics and the Adventist
Pentecostals and the Adventist atheists
and the Adventist vegetarians who love
meat there are all kinds of things
but the Adventist Church as God raised
it up is the precise opposite to the
Roman
Church how do you know we're the true
church of
god let's look at the church the devil
hates are you following
me did you hear what I said let's look
at the church the devil hates go to
Revelation
12 Revelation 12
we read from verse
7 and there was war in heaven where did
the war begin in heaven Michael and his
angels fought against the dragon and the
dragon fought and his angels and
prevailed not neither was their place
found anymore in heaven and the Great
Dragon was cast out that old serpent
called the devil and Satan which
deceiveth the whole world world he was
cast out into the Earth and his angels
were cast out with him verse 7 says a
War began in heaven
now let's read verse
13 and when the dragon saw that he was
cast where un the Earth he persecuted
the woman come on which brought forth
the Manchild
now in heaven whom did Satan fight
directly come on
Jesus you see Adventists have a way of
interpreting the Bible it's called the
Great
controversy everything that happens on
Earth generally and in your life
personally puts you on one side or other
of the great controversy the great
controversy is a battle between come on
Christ and Satan it began long before
the world was made it continues today
now it began in heaven but Satan was
thrown out so he trans transferred his
hostility to the earth now he cannot
reach Christ directly so he hurts Christ
how by the church you see he hurts the
church and thereby hurts
Christ you prefer me to slap you than to
slap the baby in your
arms are you listening to me if I were
to slap that baby in your arm you'd feel
it more than the baby and that would be
the last day of my life on this Earth
are you follow following me Satan gets
to God or to Christ by hurting the
church and so now verse 17 says verse 13
says he persecuted the woman that
brought forth the Manchild now that's
the early church but the early church
have Generations that descended
descended descended Now read verse 17
and the dragon was wroth with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
her seed which keep the Commandments of
God and have the testimony of Jesus
Christ now we have the Commandments of
God the testimony of Jesus Christ he
made he went to make war with the
remnant of her seed now keep in mind
Revelation has many many
women symbolizing churches you say to me
explain that go to Revelation
17 Revelation 17 we'll read verse five
this is about Babylon the great or
the great system of false religions and
false
worship let me read from verse four and
a woman was arrayed in purple and
scarlet color and decked with gold
precious stone and Pearls having a
golden cup in her hand full of
Abominations and filthiness of her
fornication Revelation 17:4 Now read
verse 5 and upon her forehead come on
was a name written mystery Babylon the
great carefully now the mother of
harlots
that's fine and Abominations of the the
mother of harlots Babylon has many
daughters but cats give birth to little
cats are you with me are you Lions give
birth to little
lions Babylon gives birth to little
Babylon etes is
that they're just like she is so in fact
Revelation has many women many false
churches but Revel 12:17 says and the
dragon was wroth come on with the
woman not the
women I may be politically incorrect but
I'll say it
boldly Satan is
mad as a
Hatter with one
church the church that highlights the
Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ in a in the
ministry of someone with a prophetic
gift and that church is the 7th Day
Adventist
Church no other church on the face of
the Earth defends and upholds the law of
God I'll tell you something else why you
can reasonably conclude which church is
God's Church go to Matthew
28 Matthew 28 reading from Verse 18
you have that not yet all
right you have it
now and Jesus came and spake unto them
saying all power is given unto me come
on in heaven and in Earth go ye
therefore and teach most Nations All
Nations now where did Christ send his
disciples what is All Nations the whole
world the Church of Christ should be
found where all over the world listen to
me carefully there are only two
churches that come close to meeting that
requirement two name them the Catholic
church and the
administ the United Nations lists about
230 countries as separate Sovereign
Nations about 230 the S Adventist Church
is about roughly 210 of
them the only other church that comes
close is a Catholic
Church forget the others and I speak
with respect now you've got you've got a
choice the Catholic Church qualifying as
God's church end time church or the 7day
Adventist Church listen to me carefully
the end time Church keeps the
Commandments of God are you with me
let's look at the Commandments of
God there are 10 of them God has never
changed them has the Catholic Church
changed God's law yet yes or no yes give
me an
example the fourth one they moved they
said they moved the Sal they said from
the seventh day to the first but only
God can make something holy are you with
me no human being can make something
holy and so they keep Sunday secular
they can't keep it holy I tell you
something what other change did they
make in God's
law the what Idols they remove
commandment two because commandment two
forbids the making and worship of idols
and so in the Catholic catechism it does
not
appear which meant now they had nine
Commandments instead of 10 what did they
do they went to commandment 10 and split
it into two commandment 10 says Thou
shalt not cover thy neighbor's house
Thou shalt not cover thy neighbor's wife
now it's man servant maid servant Ox ass
whatever nor anything that is thy
neighbors the church split that into two
and said one is th shall not cover thy
neighbor's wife Thou shalt not cover thy
neighbor's house they made that two
Commandments but reason with me if you
do that you have to make every element
in that commandment a commandment
because it said Thou shalt not cover thy
neighbor's house Thou shalt not cover
neighbor's wife nor his man servant nor
his made servant no his Ox no his ass
nor anything that is thy neighbors each
one has to be a commandment if you start
splitting them I hope you're following
me so the church split in the 10 into
two to come up with the original
10 let me show you something
else that the church has done with
respect to God's
law in the Catholic version of The Ten
Commandments as in their cath now in
their Bible is the same thing as in your
Bible but most instruction is not out of
the Bible it is out of the catechism are
you following
me what did you just say are you
following me all right in the catechism
give me the first four Commandments in
the Catholic catechism just short
versions Thou shalt have no other gods
before me that's correct
two
what Thou shalt not take the name of
Lord God in vain that's two in your
Bible that's that's three what's number
three for
them remember the Sabbath day what's
number four honor your father of your
mother okay listen to me
carefully on the Catholic table you know
Moses was given two tables on their
first table they have no gods don't take
God's name in vain keep the Sabbath day
holy but that's all they right they
never they never go on to say which day
it is they just say keep the Sabbath
holy that's it and number four is honor
thy father and thy mother now in the
Bible version honor thy father and thy
mother is on what stone what table the
second table for whom is the first table
demonstrating of uh affection and
loyalty and God the first four is pecul
are peculiarly for God service
relationship with God the second six
your fellow man but in the Catholic
version as in the
catechism where is where are father and
mother
found in the first table which shows
Love For
Whom so they've put father and mother on
the Divine side are you are you are you
following me under the Now who is the
Holy
Father you know he's God on Earth yeah
he's God on Earth according to their
he's God on Earth he then is on the
first
table that's reserved for
God in the Bible mother and father are
on the second
table so we have a man occupying the
spot that should be occupied by God
because in their mind the pope is verily
God on Earth you cannot get more
Blasphemous so even though that church
competes with our church with respect to
its presence all over the world its
relationship with God's law disqualifies
it from being
considered God's last day Church what
else can I give to you to make a correct
Choice the doctrine of that
church does the church allow you to pray
to Saints yes or no because they believe
that Saints are alive but we know the
Bible teaches when you're dead you're
dead until Christ raises you up the
church allows you to talk to Mary
because Mary is a sort of assistant
savior if you don't get something from
Christ ask Mary and she'll get it for
you the church says a priest can forgive
your sins the Bible says who can forgive
sins but
God the church says in communion the
wine and the wafer literally become the
blood and the body of Jesus and the
Bible says don't drink blood not even
Jesus is blood don't drink
blood the church says there's a place
called
Purgatory it's not heaven it's not hell
it's a place where you go before you're
finally qualified for heaven Purgatory
was developed by Augustine who lived
from 3 54 to 430 ad about 3 to 400 years
after Christ that's who developed
purgatory and it entered into the
Catholic teaching Purgatory is not in
the Bible that Church believes that
Sinners go to hell and they burn how
long forever the Bible says the wages of
sin is death not Eternal burning someone
burning forever is not
dead am I talking to
myself but that church says Sinners burn
forever and ever and ever and ever the
Bible says behold I come quickly and my
reward is with me to give every man
according as his work which means god is
proportional who has sinned forever and
ever nobody then nobody can burn forever
and ever because he gives according to
their work but let me see how let me
show you how good God is who has been
righteous forever and ever none of us
but we live with Christ for how long ah
forever so God blesses forever but he
punishes for short
time the Catholic Church the Adventist
Church you look at the evidence the
Adventist Church represents God's last
day Church God's Remnant Church on this
Earth next
question but let me say quickly when we
say the Catholic Church the Roman Church
we are not referring to the members in
the
pews they have no clue what is the
magisterium
you asked the the average Catholic in
the Pew what is the magisterium and they
can tell you the magian refers to the
pope and the Bishops as the authority to
explain the Bible That's the the
fundamental meaning in the Catholic
Church the Bible is not the highest
Authority that was settled at the
Council of Trent which ran from 1545 to
1563 on and off for 18 years and the
Council of Trent it was a establish that
tradition is as high as the Bible itself
and sometimes even higher the Bible is
not the highest Authority in the
Catholic Church any honest priest will
tell you that in the 7day Adventist
Church the Bible is the highest
Authority yes we have counsel from our
servant but the Bible is the highest and
final
Authority all
right next question oh I I didn't finish
I said we're not talking to the members
in the Pew we're talking to the system
that's located where in the Vatican
which has continued for over a thousand
years 1500 and more has continued
continued continued that's why the
Antichrist is not a person no one has
lived that long the Antichrist is a
system and not a political system really
it is a religious system and the devil
is so clever he uses a religious system
because no one would expect a religious
system to persecute other churches
next
question when the Bible talks about the
mark of the beast is that a literal Mark
or the forehead and hands please
elaborate the mark of the beast and then
there's the mark of the Seal of God the
Seal of God is a
Sabbath the Sabbath commandment has his
name his territory his title Creator
Heaven and Earth he's
God the mark of the beast and that is in
the writings of the Catholic Church they
say their
Mark you can find out very very quickly
on YouTube on uh to Google it their Mark
of authority is the fact that they
changed the Sabbath from Saturday to
Sunday in other words they change what
God said that's a mark of authority that
they can take what God Said and change
it that's what they say a mark of
authority to change God's law
now their Mark is not a visible Mark in
the hand or the head the Bible says it's
on the hand or the forehead the hand
means you do it mechanically the
forehead means you really believe this
error the Seal of God is in the hand in
Deuteronomy chapter 6 bind it for front
it around thine eyes and this be also be
upon your hand the gates of your house
your post the door
everywhere the God's sign is a Sabbath
we know from uh Exodus 31:13 to17 verily
my sabbaths they shall keep for they
sign between me and you throughout your
Generations that ye may know that I am
the Lord that will sanctify you the
Sabbath is a sign of
sanctification
now when God I am might tell you too
much all let me tell you when God
made Creation in six days rested the
seventh the seventh only became holy
after God
rested are you with
me he blessed it when he had finished
his rest in other words he rested the
entire day first then he blessed it it
was not blessed while he was
resting so in effect we had seven
secular
days at the end of his rest then he
blessed that seventh day he made a
secular day holy Ela white writes God
rested first then he blessed it and gave
it to
mankind now the Sabbath is a signed I'm
the Lord that to sanctify you the same
way he Sanctified a secular Day made it
holy he can sanctify our secular lives
are you with me it is a sign that God is
able to sanctify us now when you accept
Sunday as your day of worship you have
accepted the authority of an
organization that opposes God and God's
word despite whatever else they may say
when you undertake to change God's law
and in any country the laws are the
principles by which that country
functions and those laws are condensed
in what is called the constitution of
Any Nation when you interfere with God's
Constitution you threaten his
kingdom the church has changed
it at the Council of Tren
1563 that Council was called for a
couple reasons or three reasons mainly
one to highlight Catholic teachings and
to undermine Protestant beliefs two to
try to get rid of all the abuses and
corruption in the church and to develop
some principles of operation for that
church but the main one was to undermine
Protestant teaching and to establish
Catholic teaching the council ended with
the Catholic church triumphing over the
Protestants with this argument there was
a bishop called the bishop of Regio
Catholic bishop here's what he said to
the
Protestants because the Protestants had
a war cry it was solar scriptura what
does that mean the Bible only this
Catholic bishop got up towards the end
after 18 years he said you Protestants
you claim the Bible
only yet you keep Sunday as the Sabbath
for which the Bible gives no
Authority are you following me when he
said that the Protestants had nothing to
say you claim solar scriptura Bishop
Regio said yet you accept our Authority
and we change the day without any Bible
Authority whatsoever we establish our
authority over the Bible and you accept
it by observing
Sunday anyone who knowing ly keeps
Sunday is accepting and Authority above
God that is called the mark of the beast
but let me say something quickly no one
actually has the mark of the beast now
because there isn't a formal worldwide
law requiring Sabbath observance but
that is
coming when that comes because that has
been agitated for decades quietly
Nations have tried to pass Sunday laws
to make Sunday the legal day of worship
it will happen when it happens then we
have to make a choice a man-made law or
God's law those who then choose a
man-made law would have chosen the mark
of the beast but as now no one has the
mark of the beast because that man-made
law is not yet
enforced the Seal of God the Sabbath
acknowledging God's Creator and savior
sustainer Almighty and divine
and having a right to rule the universe
the Sabbath is a sign between God and
his people Sunday is a sign between
people and the Catholic Church even if
you're
Pentecostal because Pentecostal skip
Sunday the Pentecostal Church began
about 1903 1904 somewhere in the first
decade of the 1900s that's when they
began the Catholic church was in
existence over a thousand years before
that and having put Sunday into the
world the Pentecostals came and adopted
Sunday the the Presbyterians came and
adopted Sunday the Methodist came and
adopted Sunday you name it the the
Baptist came adopted Sunday the
Jehovah's Witnesses came adopted Sunday
the Mormons came adopted Sunday the Holy
Rollers came adopted Sunday bushiri came
adopted
Sunday huh each adoption of Sunday is an
adoption of the authority of the
Catholic Church no matter what else they
may
say you've accepted a power that places
itself above
God sometimes I say Pentecostals are
Catholics because they worship on the
Catholic day again I say it's the
Catholic Church's day in the Council of
Leo deia 364 ad about 340 years after
Jesus went back to heaven the council
met and made it illegal to worship on
Sabbath the punishment for that was
being cast out of God's kingdom how they
could do that I don't know the Seventh
Day Adventist Church one of the reasons
Christ came Isaiah 42:21 is to magnify
the law and make it
honorable all 10 all right that was a
long
response what does the Sabbath was made
for man and not man for the Sabbath mean
let me say something else about this the
Sabbath let me come back let me I didn't
finish go to John 6 let me show you
something we read verse
66 of John
6 verse
66 are you there read with me please
from that time many of his disciples
went back and walked no more with him
they left Jesus now why why because
Jesus kept saying Eat My Flesh and drink
my blood they did not understand what he
meant now the Jews didn't drink blood
the Jews were not cannibals so when he
said drink my blood and eat my flesh
they were I mean they were
shocked so they left him many of us
don't understand the words of Christ and
we don't leave him physically but we
leave him in the
mind then said Jesus unto the 12 verse
67 will he also go away read 68 for me
nice and loud
then Simon Peter said what Lord to whom
shall we go thou Hast the words of
eternal life pause think with me quiz's
question what was the reason Peter gave
for staying with
Christ what he was
preaching thou Hast the words of eternal
life which means when you choose a
church the only question you need to ask
is what do they
teach not if there's a grand piano or if
they have a choir or if the pastor
drives or flies with a little plane what
do they teach not if the members are
perfect Jesus said have I not chosen you
12 one of you is a devil Jesus was the
pastor of the early church one of his
members was a devil but that church was
still the Church of God because the
teachings were
biblical when you look at the Adventist
Church what we preach is is biblical are
we all Saints oh no do we have some
judases yes they didn't come today but
we have some judases are you with all
right next
question what do the Sabbath was made
for men and not men for the 17 all
right did you have Heroes day
yesterday okay did you celebrate it it
was given to you but for what purpose to
hon are
you did you were businesses closed on on
Heroes day many yes were schools closed
yes why the day is given to the school
you have a day off the business is you
can close but not to talk about you to
honor whom the heroes the Sabbath was
made for man that man May on the Sabbath
do what honor the Creator made for man
does not mean it is man's personal
possession the Bible repeatedly says the
Sabbath is God's
day but entrust it to us that on that
day we will make him the center of our
lives without distraction from work or
school or whatever else yes the Sabbath
was made for man not man for the Sabbath
on that day we spay special attention we
pay special attention to our Savior our
creator without the burden of work and
any other secular distraction all right
next question in keeping by the way okay
go ahead go ahead
in keeping the Sabbath should our cattle
not go for grazing with the Herdman and
added to that well no no just one at a
time in keeping the Sabbath should we do
what should our cattle not go for
grazing with them oh yes the cattle
should go and graze do you have Sabbath
lunch well your cattle should have
Sabbath lunch
too the Sabbath isn't intended to make
us cruel and
harsh your cattle your animals need to
feed you're not breaking the Sabbath by
giving them water and food they need to
eat Jesus said if your animal Falls in a
pit on the Sabbath take it
out it's lawful to do good it's not
lawful to work it's lawful to do good
please feed your cows on the S now don't
go above and beyond and work but make
sure they have what they need so you
need minimal effort to make sure they're
taken care of you can't let animals
suffer because you're in church singing
loudly no no no no make sure your
animals are fed and taken care of
because God made animals and he made
them to have fellowship with us the
Bible you're T to treat animals nicely
there's a verse that says if you're
walking down the street you see a bird's
nest put it back in the tree with a
little bird put it back in the tree love
animals take care of them Ela tells us
in Patriarchs and Prophets those Before
the Flood they love to kill animals and
that love for killing animals LED them
to disregard love for human life because
all life is from God and the physical
life as an animal is like the physical
life in a human being next question or
the next part of that question well on
that question the um grazing with the
Herdman your worker mhm can they go with
the worker the well that depends on how
you arrange that the work The Herder
should not work on Sabbath but the
animals must be taken care of I have to
leave that member to figure that out I
can't give the details all I can say is
the animals cannot be left to suffer on
the Sabbath but with God help the owner
can find somewhere to so manage his
stock that he does not end up working or
having someone work for him there's
always a way to honor God when he wants
obedience always a
way is buying on Sabbath a sin yes
yes and selling mhm mhm next
question no business on
Sabbath what if I stay home and keep
Sabbath and honor God what's the point
of joining church and being baptized
where I find people with problems and
bad attitudes and characters but you
have problems and bad attitudes
too huh come join the family are you
following me a family of bad attitudes
and problems we all need Jesus are you
following me didn't I tell you Jesus
said have I not chosen you 12 one of you
is a devil come to church now let's go
to uh Leviticus 23 a lot of people think
I can stay home and worship God you're
wrong not if you can come to church
you're wrong I speak your respect but I
want to speak clearly you're dead wrong
Leviticus 23 let's understand something
about the
Sabbath let me pray again father as I
continue tell me what to tell your
beautiful people that you may be
glorified in their lives in Jesus name I
pray
amen you have Leviticus
23 and the Lord spake unto Moses saying
Speak unto the children of Israel and
say unto them concerning the Feast of
the Lord which he shall Proclaim to be
holy convocations even these are my
Feast Now read verse
three six days thou shal labor but the
seventh day is the Sabbath of what's the
next expression a holy
convocation part of Sabbath observant is
coming together to Fellowship it is a
holy
convocation when you deliberately stay
at home you are going contrary to what
God requires on that holy day a holy
convocation of coming together let me
tell you something about worshiping by
yourself the Bible says be sober be
vigilant because your adversary the
devil as a roaring lion walketh about
seeking whom he may devour now when
predators are hunting they're looking
for four kinds of prey the
old the
sick the young or the injured I think
one of those three if you watch any clip
of cheetah hunting or a
they will identify an animal in the herd
and they will run past other animals to
get to that one because they identified
a weakness the devil like a roaring lion
walketh about looking for isolated
Christians because if you think you're
all right by yourself you are wrong the
Bible says forsake not the assembling of
yourselves as the manner of some is
especially as you see the day coming and
that day is the day of atonement we're
in that day now and on the day of
atonement four things were required one
afflict your souls they Soul sins are
forgiven two don't work three fast four
assemble at the the the Tabernacle
that's a group worship four things were
emphasized on the day of
atonement confess your sins let afflict
your soul fast don't work gather for
worship around the Tabernacle now we are
are in the antitypical day of atonement
which began October 22 1844 we must
emphasize make sure your sins are
forgiven fasting sometimes don't make
work the object for which you live and
make sure you press together for worship
as often as possible by deliberately
staying home you are opposing the spirit
of the day of atonement in which we live
the Sabbath is a holy convocation not a
day for isolation if coming together is
possible you are in spiritual danger by
worshiping by yourself when you have the
option of group
worship next
question what is the danger of being
spiritually Rich spiritually rich Let's
go to Revelation chapter
3 Revelation chapter 3
let's
read verse
17 are you there Revelation 3:17 what
does that
say because thou sayest I am rich and
increase with goods and have need of
nothing spiritually Rich am rich
nothing and noce not that thou art
wretched miserable poor blind and naked
someone who considers himself
spiritually rich and that wealth is not
Christ himself is blind to his true
condition it is dangerous and this is
the description of God's Church in the
end time that's us the Leo Dean church
I'm rich increas with Goods I have need
of nothing the church mortgage is paid
off every member has a car every member
has a job everything's going fine we
have no real need need for divine
intervention it's a dangerous spiritual
condition to think you spiritually rich
and that richness is not the life of
Christ so spiritually rich is what the
leod Deans said of themselves but God
has an entirely different view you're
wretched miserable poor blind and naked
because he or she who does not see the
true condition is spiritually poor no
matter how many material things that
person may possess because we must see
things the way God sees them
always try to see the world through
God's eyes you'll see an entirely
different world next question how do you
identify your spiritual gift several
ways one your parents can tell you what
they observe in you two the
church one of the gifts of the church is
the gift of
discernment and church members observing
you particularly as you grow up he
should be this or she should be that
church members can tell you I mean
senior church members MERS I believe you
ought to consider this field or that
field I mean that was done to me even
though at an early age the Lord
impressed me I ought to preach but
people would tell me you ought to preach
or you ought to teach they constantly
told me that so one way is to listen to
members of the church who have observed
you another way your parents because
they know you another way is to take a
test the church has several spiritual
gifts tests or you may take an aptitude
test which also identifies if it's a
good test what your strengths are you
can do those things and of course number
one you ask
God God is a God who loves to talk ask
God as you make an effort to find out
for yourself don't ask God and fold your
arms ask him as you make concentrated
efforts to find out and the Lord will
guide you but as you do that don't be
idle whatever you're doing do your best
so when the gift is identified you will
come to that gift with a habit of
excellent
work but everyone has a gift
because that's how the church is built
up everyone has a gift and it's sad when
a person never uncovers that
gift all right next
question why is anointing oil not used
by our elders and pastors who says it's
not
used who said that I don't mean don't
identify yourself but you're not present
at every Church how do you know
anointing all is not used I've seen it
used all over the place the Bible
doesn't tell us how often to use it it
just says it's one way to deal with the
sick anointing Mark 6 verse verse 13
they went out and anointed many that
were with with oil many that were sick
and heal them James uh
54-16 anoint with oil and the prayer of
faith shall save the sick so anointing
with all is biblically required but the
Bible doesn't tell you how often to do
it that's up to the person who requests
it or the leaders of the church who
notice it needs to be done but I've seen
it
done I have done it
all right next question the teaching Aid
of a picture or image used for Jesus
Christ holding a lamp in his hand does
it amount to idol worship no no it's a
pictorial representation we learn by
touching we learn by seeing we learn by
hearing it's not idol worship at all
when the Israelites were bitten by
snakes God told Moses build a broen a
bro a Brazen serpent put it on a stick
and he told me look at it it was visual
but think of Christ that thing
represented Christ because Christ took
our sins to deliver us and so no having
a picture or an animal picture something
to teach children now children learn
very well visually that's not
idolatry since we are saved by grace
does that mean entry into heaven is
automatic is
automatic how do you say no in
Africans yeah that one mhm it is
it is absolutely not automatic M it is a
daily walk with God now if probation
closes and you he that is righteous let
him be righteous still ah okay but until
that happens it's a daily walk with God
entrance into the Heavenly kingdom is
not automatic because you can leave
Christ if you leave him there's no hope
of entering God's kingdom no matter the
fact that some Churches teach once saved
always saved so get saved then you go to
the wh house the casino the gambling Den
whatever that's not the way the Bible
teaches you have to walk with God that's
why Jesus said abide in me Jesus said
Matthew 2413 he that abideth unto the
end he that endureth unto the end You'
got to hanging
there with Christ as long as you're in
Christ you're guaranteed you step out of
Christ you lose that guarantee but the
guarantee is Christ not you you don't
automatically go to heaven because you
got once you could give your life to
Christ it must be a continual renewal
continual
renewal next question can Satan cast
himself out
no absolutely not nor does he have any
desire to do that no he
doesn't Christ cast him out he doesn't
cast himself out Satan gets into you and
wants to stay keep you captive he
doesn't cast himself
out now
the devil is so
tricky he may cast out one of his
people to make you think working through
some false prophet he may cast out one
of his people but how many demons were
in the gatherin demoniac Legion at
minimum 2,000 he could cast out one the
1,000 whatever 999 left so the devil is
not in the business of casting out his
people completely and entirely but he
may trick you no no no only Christ
casted out the devil and his
cohorts is the 144,000 in Revelation
symbolic or literal the church has no
fixed position some Bible scholars say
literal some say
symbolic either one has
benefits if you say symbolic and you
focus on the character not so much the
number or if you say it's literal you
can refer to the fact that at the flood
only eight people were saved when Sodom
was destroyed one righteous man came out
when Christ went back to Heaven a few
disciples in an upper room so God has
always had a few and so 144,000 out of 7
or 8 billion we have seen evidences of
very few following God so either way but
the church has no fixed official
position on
144,000 but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't study it mhm the Bible says
drink a little bit of wine is it wrong
to drink wine yeah yes well drop the
word wine alcohol perhaps a better word
because the wine the the word for wine
in the Bible can be fermented or not it
depends on the the the the context in
which you're reading now God can't say
one thing in one book and say something
in another book go to Proverbs Chapter
20 God does not speak out of both
corners of his mouth as people
say Proverbs 20 let's read verse one
you have Proverbs chapter 20 verse
one what does that say wine is a mocker
strong drink is Raging whosoever is
deceived thereby is not wise now in that
verse wine is condemned is that clear
then what did Jesus
turn from water in John Chapter 2 at the
wedding what did he make with the
water what do you mean by wine grape
juice because it was Jesus speaking
through Solomon who said wine is a
marcker strong drink is
Raging in John Chapter 2 he turned water
into the word wine there means the grape
the fruit of the vine grape
juice not alcohol that numbs the
senses you want to take a little wine
take a little grap
juice and ser and preserve your neurons
even a little alcohol affects your
judgment what I said even a little
alcohol affects your judgment and
damages the fine nerves that you have in
your brain and the brain is no organ to
damage
deliberately next question please share
your vegetarian diet with us because
sometimes we lack such information what
do you mean you lack such
information a vegetarian diet is a diet
that does not include meat as a practice
when God made Adam and Eve in Genesis
1:29 he said behold I've given you every
herb bearing seed which is upon the face
of all the Earth and every tree into
which is the fruit of a tree yielding
seed to you it shall be for me and to
every beast of the earth and to every
fowl of the air and to everything that
creepeth upon the Earth wherein there is
life I have given every green herb for
meat God's Arrangement was every living
thing should e uh plant every living
thing
ELO white writes I don't remember
where God allowed the race to eat meat
to shorten their
lives because God does not like Sinners
living
long God allowed that long lived race
right to eat flesh to shorten their
lives
every time you bite into a chicken leg
you shortening your
life are you with me
mhm the purpose of meat arranged by God
is to kill
you sooner than you ought to
die so it's not to spread sin all over
the place people say well Jesus had fish
how often did he have
it how many times can you point to
Christ eating fish or lobsters or crabs
or snakes whatever how often let me tell
you something else now for those of you
who say Christ had meat Christ did not
live in the antitypical day of
atonement since 184 October 22 1844 we
are in the literal day of atonement
spiritually now in this typical during
the Jewish era no anim products were
brought into the most holy
place are you with me no meat was
brought into the most holy Place meat
was brought in to the holy place during
the other days and the priest would
consume meat in there as a way of
identifying with a
sinner no meat was ever brought into the
most holy place we are now in the most
holy Place phase of Christ
Ministry when Christ was on the earth he
was not in that phase so you and I are
living in a different historical ERA
with respect to prophecy and in that era
no meat was brought into the most holy
Place young brother said amen and he got
no support from
anybody now I'm not telling you don't
eat meat I'm going to be telling you
what the authorities say the Bible and
our commentator sister white what she
writes she said
meat lies at the foundation of almost
all the cancers that people
suffer meat flesh
food is is a cause of so much of the
cancers from which people
suffer I'm not telling you what to eat
I'm just telling you what the spiritual
authorities tell us by the way the
purpose of diet is to keep us fit to do
God's
work that's the fundamental purpose of
diet to keep us fit to do God's work
sickly people can't serve God as well as
they ought so God gave us a diet to keep
us fit not necessarily to live long but
to live well and to be active in God's
service all right let's get to the next
question because I keep seeing all these
guilty faces get to the next question
all right what's the next question is it
okay for SDA singing groups to charge
money during CD launches book a Sunday
church venue and pay for that booking
why
not why not there are different ways to
work some people work at Checkers some
people work at the bank some work at the
gas station some work selling
CDs don't sell them on
Sabbath you publish a book you sell
it why can't I publish my CD it's a form
of work Paul made tents and he sold them
if your profession is producing music
that's your profession but don't work on
Sabbath and don't overcharge people
because you're Christian business person
don't produce rap
music or rock music or whatever else you
produce in am media all right and the
Sunday church venue the Sunday church
venue the what to book a Sunday church
venue for the concert let's say
book a a Sunday church venue for the
concert I don't have a definitive word
on that but a building is a
building don't we rent our buildings to
Sunday
churches yes we
do it's a common well perhaps not in
theia it's a common practice United
States we rent our churches to Sunday
churches it's a common practice we rent
Sunday churches to have our
services m we
do so I'm not telling you what to I'm
simply saying Adventists rent from
Sunday
churches some Sunday churches rent from
Adventists there was a the president of
my conference the Lake Region conference
he used to Pastor an Adventist Church
that rented from a Sunday
church and the Sunday church lost its
pastor and what happened they asked him
now he was pastoring two churches one
made on Sunday one made on
Saturday but as always ask God what
would you have me to do always ask God
your highest Authority Psalm 32:8 I will
instruct thee and teach thee in the way
which Thou shalt go Psalm 25:4 show me
thy ways oh Lord teach me thy paths
always ask
God did Jesus go to the house of Sinners
to have dinner yes but he didn't go to
participate in the sins he went to
present himself as as a source of light
and life but he went to the house of
Sinners next question does the time of
having Lord's Supper be only during the
dinner time the Lord the Bible doesn't
tell us when in the day to have the
Lord's Supper no how often it simply
says as often as he eat this bread and
drink my blood ye to show the Lord's
death till he come 1 Corinthians 11:26
the time of day is not stressed but we
tend to do it once a quarter during the
midday service on Sabbath but if you
read Acts 20 Acts 2 verse uh 242 to 47
they were breaking bread daily those new
converts I guess they were very excited
they were breaking bread from house to
house daily always together for that
person who said I can worship by myself
next question is it okay for a Christian
to have a cash loan and should it be
tithed to tithe is based on your
increase if you given something you
didn't have before you have
increased and God says I want
some because all of it belongs to me and
if I want I can take
it we tithe
increase recognizing God is the rightful
owner of everything and then we leave it
to God to bless us you cannot give God
too much
so any increase you have acknowledge God
and watch God bless your
life as a business owner
something when I was a little boy here's
how we were taught about tithe which is
based on
increase if someone gave you a shirt for
Christmas we were told evaluate the the
price of the shirt and return a
TI because a shirt is increased if the
government assesses your wealth do they
only look at Cash
do they look at precious metals do they
look at land how many houses do you have
do you have a boat a plane a submarine
they look at everything you have to
determine your
wealth back then in the Old Testament
way back people didn't have
cash they brought their farm
products I was in a certain country
preaching and this person came to me
with a smart question I am a farmer how
do I return a tithe I said you have a
piece of land yes cut it up into 10
pieces whatever grows in this piece
committed to God that goes to God sell
it in the market give the money to the
church I tell them you'll be surprised
that more fruit or products grow in that
little square than in all the other
nine always consider
God because everything is his and he can
take it but God is so good he made seven
days he kept
somebody say amen for a good
God God made uh all the trees he kept
one and told Adam leave it
alone God says for 100 uh I almost said
poola $100
million give me
10 come on God is a nice person now
could God have said give me 90 and you
live on
10 but he doesn't God could could have
said give me six days do everything in
one God could have told Adam all the
trees are
mine that one alone is yours but that's
not the way God functions God makes it
possible for us to obey
him next question
H oh okay next
question as a business owner is the
amount after paying employees and builds
what one should tithe how should tithing
be done in general you tithe
your increase your profit let's say you
have a business your profit is
$500 you type that you see God must get
his first not your employees God must
get his first not the government now the
government takes theirs ahead of timee
because the government doesn't trust you
to give it or trust me so they take it
out and then people say Let me give
tithe on what's left wrong you give
tithe on a gross not the net if God were
to love us on the net he would have sent
an angel to die not Jesus are you
following me and that would not have
worked God loves us on the cross we must
return on the
gross
MH always find ways to give not find
ways to take
back was tithe a temporal
Arrangement well it's Arrangement until
the new world but it's an active
Arrangement right now you can trace it
all the way back when Abraham came from
the battle in Genesis
14 the Bible says he gave tithe to
melkisedek where did Abraham get that
habit from someone taught it to him
tithe goes all the way the concept of
tithe something reserved for God may be
traced back to the tree of the knowledge
of Good and Evil God reserved that for
me don't touch it don't mess with it
this is mine the concept of tithe being
exclusive for God that tree was
exclusive for him don't play with it
stay away from
it God's tithe must not be used
to deal with emergencies the tithe is
Holy do not touch it turn it into the
storehouse the Church of God let God
demonstrate his power to take care of
you next question what is the symbolic
principle of tithe in the Adventist
Church tithe simply says you acknowledge
God as the rightful owner of everything
and you acknowledge the fact that God is
trying to take selfishness out of your
life by requiring that you give him a
certain portion of your income the
purpose is to cure us of selfishness
that's the way we are
naturally God doesn't need money what do
you do with money but he wants to purify
us of selfishness and greed so give me a
tithe support the work think of other
people
mhm part of what was revealed to John in
Revelation was the souls crying under
the altar yet the same Bible says the
dead know nothing please help clear the
misconception in addition God told Cain
that the blood of his brother Abel cries
to him from the ground sometimes Bible
writers apply human characteristics to
non-human objects let's go to Psalm
114 Psalm
114 you have that
when Israel came out of Egypt the house
of Jacob from a people of strange
language Judah was a sanctuary and
Israel his Dominion Now read the next
verse the sea saw it and fled now does
the sea
run what is the writer referring to The
Parting of the Red Sea he says the sea
saw it and
fled giving human characteristics to a
non-human thing keep reading geord
was driven back because 40 years later
they crossed Jordan so when they when he
parted the Red Sea the sea fled when it
crossed Jordan TR was driven back the
mountains skip like Rams and the little
Hills like Lambs now the writer talks to
the Sea what ill the O seed that thou
fled thou Jordan thou was driven back ye
mountains that you skip like Rams and ye
little Hills like Lambs he is giving
personality to non-living things it is a
style of
writing go to Psalm 9
8 Psalm
98 let's read the next to the last verse
what does that say of Psalm 98 the next
to the last verse what does that
say let the what floods clap their hand
now wait a minute have you ever seen a
flood with a hand no the writer is
simply giving human characteristics to
try to express a thought let the floods
clap their hands let the hills be
choiceful together before the Lord well
how do Hills do that and so when the
blood of Abel cries out it simply means
that a murder has been committed and
something has to be done eventually to
avenge that murder the souls under the
altar the martyrs who were killed The
Dead Know Nothing their blood has to be
Avenged we're using symbolic language to
make a point that's all it is
okay we're finished I have to go to
another Q&A right after this well
shortly
after let me take this moment to thank
the pastor for the joy of fellowshipping
with his church family I really enjoyed
it my dear
pastor and youve made so easy for me to
do what I came to do so easy so easy and
I thank you for that may the Lord bless
you eternally bless your family protect
your children bless your ministry may
the Lord lead you as he led Moses to
guide his church forward Upward at all
times and may God grant you an abundant
entrance into his kingdom and he comes
thank you so much for the easy way it is
for me to have worked with you I thank
you for coming every night to listen to
God's word I really do I'll miss you
terribly when I'm gone but I believe the
Lord will bring me back sooner than you
suspect it may be some other part of
Namibia but Namibia nonetheless I'm very
grateful for my little brothers who sat
in the front night after night I always
look forward to seeing you but for all
of you who came to listen to God's word
a preacher will preach to one person if
necessary but he prefers to preach them
more than one so thank you for coming
every
night my counsel to you as your
brother make time for
this there is so much chaos in the world
people don't know what to make of what's
going on but a church of Prophecy should
understand what's happening when Pharaoh
had a dream two dreams he saw five good
uh seven ears of corn that were good
seven that were thin the good consumed
the thin he saw uh seven or the thin
cons consumed the good then he saw seven
fat cattle seven thin same thing God was
trying to tell him seven years of plenty
are coming followed by seven years is a
famine Pharaoh couldn't understand the
dream he called All The
Magicians all the susers the the
traditional healers they could not
explain the only person who could
explain was Joseph A Child of God an Old
Testament Adventist can you say
Amen Nebuchadnezzar had a dream d n
Daniel chapter 2 he could not even
remember the dream far less what it
meant he called All The Magicians
astrologers
Sorcerers and calans and they came and
stood before the king the king said unto
them I have dreamed a dream and my
spirit was troubled to know the dream
Daniel 2:3 then spake the calans to the
king in syak oh King live forever tell
thy servants to dream and we will sh the
interpretation the king said unto the
calans the thing is gone from me you've
got to tell me what I dreamt and then
tell me what it meant they couldn't do
it he threatened to kill all of them but
Daniel was counted as a wise man you see
so he would have died but Daniel Prayed
with his
companions and God gave him the meaning
the only person to explain political
events to Nebuchadnezzar was a child of
God Daniel an Old Testament Adventist
now the only people on the face of the
earth now to give an intelligent
assessment of what is going on is the
people of Prophecy
not CNN not MSNBC not your NBC where I
spoke a few days ago the people of God
who understand Last Day Events and
what's
coming but you've got to study this or
you will surely be
deceived this will preserve your
children this will strengthen your home
this will broaden your mind to
understand your
schoolwork this will protect you from
harm and danger that's why Jesus says
live by every word and so I commend to
you the word of God to bless every area
of your
life if there's someone in the church
who's hurt you forgive the person if
there's someone you've hurt apologize
coming to church well dressed looks nice
visually but very often it conceals all
the sores and the warts and the
infections that lie under the nice
clothes because people don't get along
with people they have long-standing
grudges that have never been
resolved we smile every Sabbath fix
those things let the spirit of God
move thank you again so much God bless
you I love you and if we don't meet on
this side as people usually say but I
hope we do let's meet in the new world
can you say Amen because that world is
coming until then wherever you are if I
come across your mind
all I want you to say is Lord come on
put your words in that man's mouth shall
I take your love back to my wife yes or
no say yes okay I'll tell her you
treated me nicely I oh let me thank
Those Who provided food ah God bless you
God bless you when a man is far from
home he's not sure what he's going to
eat you know sometimes people bring you
dishes and you have to say grace twice
because you're not sure what's in front
of you
one's for thank you for the food the
other one is for protection but I thank
God for the good food the ladies have
given me gentlemen don't be angry but
let me talk to the ladies thank you
wherever you are thank you and may God
bless you and may your oil and flour
never run out because you've taken care
of this least of God's disciples and
apostles I really mean that God bless
you eternally little boys and little
girls
Jesus loves you and he wants you to give
your life to him he wants you to live
for him and if you do that your little
friends will see Jesus in you and
they'll come to Christ instead of your
friends turning you to Mischief you can
bring them to Jesus by you being
faithful his word and obedient to Mom
and Dad thanks again let me offer a
prayer for you can I do that
Pastor heads bowed eyes closed
dear father in
Heaven you know more than anyone how
delighted I have been with my time in
this part of the world father you know
how every night i' go to my window look
over the land and thank you for the joy
of being in the
Mia I thank you for the people your
Sabbath keeping people in specifically
and all others
generally I ask you to bless the
Adventist Church in Namibia father Wrap
Your Arms Around them preserve them from
harm and danger keep them from error let
them live so Faithfully that the church
in this country will literally be a
light that shines brighter and
brighter bless the government direct
their deliberations day
God bless our online audience that came
night after night bless the countries
they represent father in all that we do
Keep Us Faithful I pray save us when you
come in Jesus name let God's people say
amen and amen God bless
you
again God be with you till we
meet
again
daily man still
provide you
God be with you till we
meet again till we
meet till we
meet again till we meet take Jesus feet
Jesus feet till we
meet till we
meet again